[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with
economics correspondent at the spectator
kate andrews and
political editor at the new statesman
stephen bush
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the greatest cyclist jason kenney wins
his seventh gold medal on the final day
of the tokyo 2020 olympics
making him britain's best ever olympian
that's on the metro
the sun also leads with the games
celebrating team gb's
65 medals as do the express honor heroes
who lifted nation
it says picturing welsh olympic champion
lauren price
who won gold in the boxing ring
the telegraph meanwhile has the headline
too many teenagers are going to
university as the government encourages
students to take up
degree apprenticeships rishi sunak
remains focused on the economy in the
wake of the pandemic
that's on the front of the yorkshire
post after reports of rising tension
between the chancellor and prime
minister
almost out of time the climate warning
from scientists on the front of the
guardian
on the eve of an ipcc report
the daily mail has a story on the pay of
civil servants alleging ministers
want to pay those who continue to work
from home less than colleagues
who return to their desks
and joined tonight by kate andrews and
stephen
bush good evening to you both welcome um
let's start with the
metro and uh the olympics and uh
pictured there
uh stephen kenny amongst others having
won his seventh
gold sorry jason kenny why did i say
stephen
because you're stephen bush that's
what's thrown me uh jason kenny
haven't won his uh seventh goal medal
absolutely triumphant there kate
yes amazing although i would have loved
to see stephen compete as well
maybe um but it's been a
huge success for team gb matching
its wins uh in the 2012 olympics when of
course that was hosted
here in london so to match that kind of
success on the other side of the world
and in tokyo is is a huge win overall um
the metro is also flagging lauren price
who you mentioned before as well
um who secured that 22nd gold medal
uh for team gb um in in those last days
um for boxing so you know 65 medals
overall
ranking in the top five it's a big
success story and there are plenty of
hurdles along
the way of course there always are the
kinds that you know we can't even begin
to imagine
we're talking about athletes training at
the top levels but this time around they
were also dealing
with covid not just the restrictions not
just lack of fans but many of them
having to self-isolate are getting the
virus themselves so um you know huge
round of applause for coming over
overcoming the extra hurdles that are
already there and a really really good
turnout for team gb
yes and it is a surprise success isn't
it stephen
and especially as we had all of those
protests in japan with
local people not even wanting the
olympics to take place there and
continuing to process throughout
yeah i mean it is it's yeah often you
get a boost from hosting the olympics
but um
the japanese government and particularly
the prime minister looks like they're
going to get the reverse of a boost
polls very bad for him as a result of
that but in some ways
actually our success now is the result
of actions taken by a
now you know long distance prime
minister john major big sports fan
who used national lottery funding after
the disaster of i think the 1994
olympics
um to really um make team gb competitive
uh in the olympics
uh that funding then boosted by tony
blair won the olympics in 20 after it
won the bid to get the olympics in 2012
but
it really is uh this really is you know
the medal team that john major built
actually
let's uh move on away from the olympics
to um
the front page of the telegraph and this
is a very interesting story
uh the headline there too many teenagers
going to university uh who exactly is
saying this
and why
so with a level results upon as sarah
peter
be the founder and chairman of the
sutton trust and described here by the
telegraph as an influential figure
in the field of social mobility is
saying that he's actually concerned
by the numbers of applicants we're now
seeing to university and the number of
people going
it's thought that this number is going
to continue to go up because of the
system we've put in place for covid
which is based on predicted grades we're
seeing an inflation in the number of
students who are getting
a's or a stars which means that we
should expect to see
even more students going to university
now what sir lampe is trying to push is
the idea of apprenticeships is that
sometimes students will take on the
burden of debt to go to university
and then come out and realize that they
didn't need that debt necessarily to
pursue the careers they want to have
the problem is that the more that the
government seems to interfere with
apprenticeships
the worse the program seemed to go um
when it brought in that apprenticeship
levy in 2017
apprentices dropped by a quarter just
two years
after that levy was brought in of course
last summer we had boris johnson
almost saying off the cuff that he
thought every young person should have a
guaranteed
apprenticeship but it does seem that the
more the government interferes with
with such things the more difficult they
are to secure so it's all about figuring
out how we can actually enable business
to offer these opportunities and how we
as a society need to be better
recognizing that the pursuit of
university or an apprenticeship
is equally as good just fundamentally
different based on what that student
wants to do
in the future with their career it is a
lot about perception though isn't it
stephen because it
you do get the feeling that
apprenticeships are still viewed as the
poor
relative compared to it to a university
place
yeah it's ultimately about yeah that
perception also then if you get an
apprenticeship
uh and you know succeed in your first
chosen career and then as people often
do when they've
succeeded in one career decide they'd
like to do something else there's a
perception that an apprenticeship is not
a sort of universal
sort of passport to various industries
in the way that a broad degree often is
which is partly of course about things
that the government can't control
exactly as kate says it's about
how employees react employers directors
but the point that um tabitha lampal is
is raising particularly is about that
debt which obviously of course is
is not really borne by individual
graduates but by uh the exchequer it's
really just a stealth income tax and a
way to hide government borrowing so if
you have
lots of people who are getting that
degree but not getting the earnings
boost
then essentially you've actually just
got a large increase in government debt
now some people say you don't need to
worry about that
but it is if you are the kind of person
who thinks that we should be concerned
about the amount of government debt
it is a big problem uh that so many
people and so many graduates are now
becoming so
indebted uh because it does all get
passed on to the taxpayer in the end
kate let's have a look at the yorkshire
post next and this story uh suggesting
that uh
rishi sunak and boris johnson are at
odds
in terms of uh the approach towards the
economy
um they're suggesting that that um well
there was
previously there was a story about boris
johnson suggesting that he might
demote rishi sunak because they are at
adult um what more does this article
tell us
well speaking of tax and debt and the
state of the public finances
the problems uh that the uk is going to
have with these decisions down the road
seem to be moving from
the policy to the personal and over the
past week
and we've seen quite a few briefings
about inflated tensions between the
prime minister
and his chancellor rishi sunak and and
as you mentioned
um over the weekend uh the the
revelation that he suggested
that he could be demoted um now number
10
and others are um suggesting to some
extent that this might be overstated
and yet it's they're not denying that it
was said
um i think there are a few things going
on here first of all let's be honest
it's august
um uh you know a small flare-up a bit of
tension between
number 10 and number 11 might not be
getting this much attention if we had
uh bigger politics going on but there's
no doubt that the prime minister and the
chancellor for a long time now since the
beginning
since rishi soon that came on have had
different perspectives on the state of
the uk's finances
boris johnson is more comfortable with
debt he's more comfortable with spending
he actually rejects the notion of
austerity he says he thinks it was a
mistake
well rishi soon as not embracing the
language of austerity he's much more
concerned about the state of the
finances
he wants to get the deficit under
control and he's
going to be not excited to but probably
more serious about uh tackling
some of the spending that's been going
on especially emergency spending to get
these things under control
so i think that policy tension is
emerging
in the personalities right now but again
perhaps slightly inflated
given the fact that the news is rather
quieter when it comes to
whitehall in august stephenie are you
surprised by this i mean
after all it is the chancellor's job to
secure financial recovery that's that's
what he's supposed to do
um no it's an open secret than the prime
minister and the chancellor are
not really aligned on economic vision
some would say because the chancellor
has one and the prime minister doesn't
really
um but of course uh the particular issue
is that
rishi sanak is deeply concerned that
this uh extraordinary debt than we've
accrued in this time
is something he needs to worry about now
some in the conservative party so just
treat it like walder
you know don't worry about it and that
gives you a lot more fiscal uh
maneuverability but because he does uh
have that particular view and and the
prime minister likes to spend freely
it's not i think that's going to be a
summer story this is going to get a lot
worse when we come back
in this in the september and there is a
big
you know very you know going to be a big
round about the content of that very
steer budget
to the daily mail uh very quickly kate
and this story about civil servants who
um
refused to return to the office um
should
take a pay cut because uh they're not
carrying out the same role as their
colleagues who are actually at their
desks
well there's one line that's going to
jump out i'm sure tomorrow as
everybody's discussing the front pages
um about how a minister has suggested
that it's difficult to know whether or
not someone at home was
working or or watching television if we
look at the difference between the
spring lockdown in in march last year
and the winter lockdown this year
well the economy took a dip both times
it
plunged last year and actually it only
fell a few percentage points
uh and and january this year and one of
the big reasons is that
the business community built up a
lockdown resilience people adapted
they learned how to handle lockdown it
was still very economically painful
don't get me wrong
but the reality is that we know that
most workers sitting at home were
working very hard
um i think it's a little bit strange to
single out civil servants here
i think the crux of the story does have
some truth to it which is that when you
are negotiating your pay you will be
taking into account
the cost of commuting the cost of often
working in a city and having to leave
your home
and all the costs that go along with
that that might be travel that might be
food
it could be a whole host of things um
and the idea that actually people do
start
to work from home on a permanent basis
that may well affect salaries that's a
consequence of working from home that a
lot of people haven't wanted to speak
about yet
but i think the accusation that people
haven't been working
or that this is specific to government
and not also the private sector
is a bit of an odd angle but we should
be honest about the trade-offs of
working from home and the truth is that
when people go around
to renegotiate their salary to ask for a
pay raise their commuting costs
may well be a factor in these decisions
but the reality is many people say
they actually work a lot harder and many
more hours working from
home this comes ahead of the ipcc
intergovernmental panel on climate
change report due out
i'm really saying that we are out of
time a very stark warning
from scientists there kate
yes so this un panel of experts has come
together to release
um quite a major report um and it's
ahead of un
talks that will be taking place in a few
months time but of course
it's ahead of cop 26 as well which will
be taking place here in the uk
in november the centerpiece really of
the government's green agenda and it's
going to focus in
on the major changes that the report
thinks to be made in this decade
um but it's also going to be focusing on
the paris climate agreement
and whether or not countries are
actually on their path
uh to limiting heating to 1.5 c above
pre-industrial levels and let's be
honest here
most countries have dropped the ball on
this and there's been a
really bad effort to say the least of
shipping carbon emissions overseas
especially from
developed countries to less developed
countries
uh trying to take credit for things that
they're actually just shipping away so i
think there's
a a really big question mark over not
only u.n talks but also what happens at
cop 26 is it going to be more
rhetoric or are they actually going to
start to come up with solutions and
are they going to be honest with the
public about those solutions because
they are going to cost money
they are going to require some levels of
sacrifice and yet the narrative at the
moment is that we can basically have our
cake and eat it
this report i suspect uh it's out today
or it's out on monday
um and the reports to come will probably
say actually tough decisions are going
to have to be made soon
yes and uh the scientists are saying
that the fires floods and extreme
weather conditions that we've seen are
just a full
taste of of what to expect if global
heating
takes hold and we've seen we've been
reporting from greece to tonight
the fires there we've also seen the
situation in california our
correspondent there just
saying that it looks like a a war zone
um because of the the fires taking place
there
it is here isn't it uh climate change
isn't coming down the tracks it it has
arrived stephen
it has an indeed in a much smaller scale
it's you know the the floods we've had
in in london this weekend and
the flood we've had twice in london over
the course of this summer kate's exactly
right about
you know the failure of governments
across the world uh and the big task
we now have both governments and all of
us have if we are to you know
avert the catastrophe that is you know
not not distant but
arriving yeah as we speak uh
very quickly uh we've got time to have a
look at the financial times
um and this is a about story about the
the taliban one that we've been covering
ourselves with the interpreters that
have been seeking
sanctuary they've been um highlighted by
the taliban as traitors and find it
impossible to stay
in their country uh and the story
continues the financial times taking it
up there kate
yeah um horrifying violent scenes from
this weekend
um as the taliban make further gains uh
and this comes as the us is drawing down
troops and preparing to leave basically
completely by the end of the month
bringing to an end a 20-year war that
the u.s has been waging
arguably very unsuccessfully on on many
fronts
but it's a very difficult scenario uh
the pressure is on in america
it isn't across the political spectrum
frankly republicans and democrats alike
to wind down and to bring troops home
and
yet we can see already that the taliban
is taking advantage of the situation and
there's
huge worry that a full-out civil war
could break out
they are gaining incredible ground
aren't they in afghanistan as we speak
kate and steven
for the moment